- DAMN, SHE WAS FLY.
- SHE A'IGHT.
YO, MAN.
CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION?
- YEAH. WHAT?
- WHY EVERYBODY MESSING
WITH THE BATMAN?
- [clicks tongue] SEE?
THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT I'VE BEEN ASKING MYSELF.
- IT DON'T MAKE NO SENSE.
- WHY WOULD YOU DO IT?
- WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
WHY WOULD YOU TRY AND MESS
WITH THE BATMAN?
- IT'S FUTILE.
- IT IS.
- YO, REMEMBER,
HEATH LEDGER TRIED TO.
- PSH, I MEAN,
THE BATMAN'S GOT ARMOR.
AND, YOU KNOW,
SOME MARTIAL ARTS
AND MOVES--
[indistinct]
- [imitates sound
of bullets deflecting]
- IT DON'T WORK.
I GOT ARMOR.
AND THEN MARTIAL ARTS.
- COME ON.
- ALL YOU GOT IS A PURPLE SUIT
AND SOME PANCAKE MAKEUP.
- COME ON, MAN.
- I MEAN, COME ON, MAN.
BATMAN.
- WHY WOULD YOU...
both: MESS WITH THE BATMAN?
- THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING, MAN.
OH, REMEMBER
WHEN DANNY DEVITO TRIED IT?
- PSH.
- START WALKING AROUND.
- TALKING LIKE...
[both squawking]
both: COME ON, MAN.
- I MEAN, THE BATMAN IS A
MULTI-BILLIONAIRE WITH A GRUDGE.
YOU'RE JUST
A LITTLE FAT MOTHER[bleep]
IN A TUXEDO WITH AN UMBRELLA.
- EXACTLY, MAN.
- COME ON, MAN.
- IT'S LIKE A PRETEND BIRD
CAN'T MESS WITH THE BATMAN.
- NO WAY. NO WAY.
OUT OF THE QUESTION, MAN.
BUT JIM CARREY THOUGH.
- PSH, JIM CARREY THOUGH.
- JIM CARREY.
- COME ON.
"RIDDLE ME THIS.
RIDDLE ME THAT, MAN."
HOW IS ACE VENTURA
GONNA MESS WITH THE BATMAN?
- WELL PLAYED. WELL PLAYED.
- HOW IS ACE VENTURA--
- WELL PLAYED.
- "HEY, BATMAN.
I'VE COME TO GET YOU."
- [imitates whipping sound]
- AAH!
- NOW SEE.
HOW ARE YOU SUPPOSED
TO BLOCK A BATARANG
FROM GOING IN YOUR BUTT WITH
A CAREFULLY CRAFTED QUERY?
- YOU CANNOT. THAT'S HOW.
- IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
- HEY. HEY, PSH.
HEY, PSH. HEY, PSH.
- MICHELLE PFEIFFER.
- - MICHELLE PFEIFFER TRIED
TO MESS WITH THE BATMAN.
MICHELLE PFEIFFER TRIED TO MESS
WITH THE BATMAN.
- MICHELLE PFEIFFER.
- MICHELLE PFEIFFER...
- TRIED TO MESS
WITH THE BATMAN.
- MICHELLE PFEIFFER.
- GUESS WHAT,
MICHELLE PFEIFFER?
YOU AIN'T A REAL CAT!
- COME ON.
I'LL TELL YOU ONE THING.
AIN'T NO WAY YOU GONNA MEOW-S
WITH THE BATMAN.
- BUT WHAT ABOUT
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER THOUGH?
WHAT'S ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER
TRYING TO DO?
- COME ON, MAN.
- WHAT IS
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER--
FEEL THE BURN. FEEL THE BURN.
FEEL THE BURN.
- [grunts]
- IT SHOULD BE IN YOUR TRICEPS.
- COME ON, MAN.
- ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER--
- YOU CAN'T TURN UP THE AC
AND THINK THAT'S GONNA MESS
WITH THE BATMAN.
- WHAT IS IT SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING TO THE BATMAN?
GIVING THE BATMAN A COLD?
- COME ON, MAN.
- GIVING THE BATMAN
A SNIFFLE?
- MAN, TALKING
ABOUT BAT LOZENGE.
- AND YOU WERE DEFEATED.
- COME ON, MAN.
YOU KNOW,
THERE IS ONE PERSON THOUGH.
- OH, NO, NO, NO.
HERE IT COME NOW.
- THERE IS ONE PERSON
WHO COULD--
- HERE IT COMES RIGHT NOW.
- MM-HMM.
- NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
- THERE'S ONE PERSON
WHO COULD...
- HERE IT COMES RIGHT NOW.
- DID, AND SHALL AGAIN
BESTED THE BATMAN.
- NO, NO, NO.
- WHOO!
BOY, HERE IT COMES.
- HE TRAINED THE BATMAN.
HE GAVE THE BATMAN HIS SKILLS.
HE'S A MIRROR IMAGE
OF THE BATMAN
IN FIGHTING PROWESS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT...
BOTH: RA'S AL GHUL!
THAT'S RIGHT, DOG.
RIGHT THERE.
TALK ABOUT STRAIGHT UP
RA'S AL GHUL.
PLAYED BY THE INCOMPARABLE...
both: LIAM NEESON.
- SO EVEN WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE BATMAN...
both: LIAM NEESON
IS MY [bleep].